So, the last operator that I want to introduce
you to is unwind. Unwind is really cool. So
you know that we can have fields that have
arrays as their values in Mongo DB. Well, what
unwind does for us, is, for every value
of an array field on which we're using unwind,
it will create an instance of the document containing
that array field, for every value in the array.
So, in this example, we would get three different documents,
I'm representing the additional fields here using ellipses. But each of
the individual values for this particular field would be broken out
one by one into each of these three documents. All of
the other fields would be exactly the same in each
of the three documents. Now the value of doing something like
this is, well we could run a groupby stage as the
next stage of the pipeline, where we actually care about what
the individual values are and want to group on those individual
values. Now where would we want to do this? Well, one
example would be, if wanted to group based on the hash
tags included in individual tweets. Hash tags in that data set
are rolled up into an array. We could unwind them, using
Unwind. And do a groupby in the next stage. So that's
our overview of aggregation operators. As we move through the rest
of this lesson we'll be looking at each of these operators in
more detail with some very concrete examples, using the Twitter data set.